oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
uncle Joey where you been we need you
you've been slipping
oh [ __ ]
WK & z the dutch station killing [ __ ]
since 1963 you know i'm saying taking it
to the hoop always always and forever
what's happened you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey here in full effect
back and black with a white shirt on I'm
this beautiful Southern California day
it's hazy but don't get confused this
son of kill you ask black people
whenever you go to the beach and it's
hazy out black people under the palm
trees they know what I'm talking about
black power you know I love you
[ __ ] to the end anyway uncle
Joey here it's 4/20 week I hope you're
in [ __ ] training cuz it's all going
down Thursday night Oxnard the
ambulances are coming I got special
medication for people who freaked out
and [ __ ] it's over eight o'clock show
Lisa at his father and mm [ __ ] stars
you understand me so if you having down
beep you better start practicing tonight
[ __ ] beside that I got this [ __ ] to
Korean smoke before they launch that
[ __ ] duck check it out Paris [ __ ]
superglue this is blue cookies is with
short special [ __ ] smokes when he
goes out there start stuttering the
[ __ ] debt that little fat [ __ ] what
are you gonna do with him he's this
[ __ ] as can be if I had a press
conference guy wouldn't be that [ __ ]
dude I'd have somebody half that we were
in dealing who could take a class that I
had or something from time to time
anyway it's a beautiful [ __ ] week you
got the world by the balls you
understand me who gives a [ __ ] what they
think
at the end of the week it's what the
[ __ ] you're doing I'm saying remember
the old model rule number one they're
either gonna suck your dick on it gonna
suck your dick I may not be today but
it's gonna be sometime in the future if
your focus that's the key word for the
week focus anyway I'd like to drop some
of this [ __ ] superglue and now only
that have an axe not Friday to shows and
Saturday to shows don't [ __ ] around and
don't forget the podcast tonight seven
o'clock be there or be square we got a
great [ __ ] week of podcasts we're
going deep into the murky waters and
smoke some of this super glue and see
what the [ __ ] we're talking about here
yeah I had a great Easter weekend I hope
you [ __ ] did the same I hope
you found some eggs with some reefer in
it I found the [ __ ] egg with a tumor
at all you understand me that's the type
of luck I'm having these days till I
take it none I'm gonna chop it into
fours meaning a little by little what do
you think I'm all these [ __ ] do it
you know I like gets out of [ __ ]
halfway and shoots a $10 bag eh then
they wonder what the [ __ ] happened what
do you think [ __ ] happened he took
six weeks off then he went out and he
blasted with the same amount he was
blasting before we went in that's your
resistance goes down that's why tonight
I gotta start with low edibles I don't
want my [ __ ] heart to be that on my
shirt you know I'm saying anyway cut
this [ __ ] let's get the pipe ready tell
your boss it's over you ain't coming
back
what are you [ __ ] nuts or what what
did you do today I had a meeting this
morning it got beat up at jujitsu but it
don't matter I'm losing a [ __ ] half
ounce a week that's all that [ __ ]
matters always the last time you should
we lost a half ounce a week that's right
[ __ ] little commitments become big
commitments then all of a sudden I'm
flying through the [ __ ] that like the
greatest of ease the fattest gentle man
in the flying trapeze you didn't know I
knew that one ensure you can get been
dealing with some [ __ ] crooner anyway
you know I love your [ __ ] I
missed you been thinking about you I
wanted to give you the weekend off I
don't want to be do these things every
day then you finally this creepy [ __ ]
dude we keep these two on the minimum on
me when I'm not around you keep your
[ __ ] training up you understand me
you get the little [ __ ] you got a
shish kebab you take a souffle home
birthday you [ __ ] I love smoking
Lisa everything else is background music
what the reefer it takes you there leave
I mean I don't know what you're going
through nor were you feeling step away
from it you understand me
look on the floor from you that's the
circle of excellence you take a look at
that [ __ ] what do you want in
that to be a bad [ __ ] to put it in
their machine gun you know a [ __ ]
shoe that explodes whatever the [ __ ] you
want put in there for your life and look
at it every day and think about it
making life easy
trust me I'm Tanya I'm no [ __ ] you
know Johnny [ __ ] Gelson's but I'll
tell you what I've been there you
understand me and when you've been there
it's easier to break down at all
the sun's coming up you see I'm saying
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
it always is oh if it's raining snowing
sleeting you got that love juice in your
nutsack your hearts pumping who the
[ __ ] gonna stop your tank anyway I
gotta take two steps to the rear and get
out of here I'm a little [ __ ] up ain't
no idea but uh I'll catch you
[ __ ] tonight
same bat-time same bat-channel make sure
you there with your [ __ ] cape on and
get this body stuff that they listen
that's all I ask
I ask you to keep another [ __ ]
minimum Ari I don't want you to go out
and get twenty two beers and crash the
[ __ ] tricycle smoke a number
but on your favorite [ __ ] album and
just sit there and take away you want to
be maybe you're in some [ __ ] Hut in
Nebraska but you want to be a [ __ ]
Hawaii transcend yourself there you know
what when I start talking about
transcending it's time to [ __ ] get
the [ __ ] out of that means I smoke too
much grief what do you think I just came
out here happy Sabbath it missus [ __ ]
6:05 this more than like a [ __ ]
choo-choo train understand me don't look
at me with it don't be judging on uncle
Joey anyway that's the one with the fun
what are you doing with your time it's a
[ __ ] mix of all that it's a little on
the moist side I don't like my weave
moist I like a dry everybody gets a
[ __ ] bang for their buck this [ __ ]
wet we your puff it you're Buffett your
puffs and you don't get deep into the
[ __ ] THC crystals
what do you know anyway
that meal got some kick I'll see you
[ __ ] tonight seven o'clock
same bat-time same bat-channel
youtube.com slash Joey Diaz or some [ __ ]
[ __ ] hit the [ __ ] Google and
you'll find them I love you do is I'll
forget Oxnard this week Bakersfield next
week the Templar Brewing Company
Thursday night are you kidding me or
what
stay black don't forget I [ __ ] love
you guys alright see you soon
tonight seven o'clock don't [ __ ] around
don't make me come looking for you